[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui à mon coeur
que je suis rigolos ils ont dit que
j'étais rigolo c'est vraiment caché
rigolo
tulard abadie
cela dit que c'était pas rigolo
[Musique]
raté un chauffe
yanez
dans les yeux
ce garçon me traite manger écoute moi
bien tu vas tu excusez mon gars j'en ai
marre de toi moi bien tout est calme
pourquoi c'est une autre des
biens-fonds non les marques phyto très
bien photo on hâte de danse a préparé
trois à 3-3 dans sa préparer cette
semaine oui alors je te préviens
je me cherchais ambulance
pour les brosses
[Musique]
fille
aînée
yat-sen
fait l'échec
ya un peu plus de foi salut ça va avec
la bande orelsan ça va
ça va